one crews take three marker alright guys
it got a top secret mission there's no
one better for the job than my best buds
okay we're gonna break into the IMF
fault Langley in Langley that's right
it's won by the IHOP or Krueger got so
drunk he ate that blueberry pancake off
the bathroom floor muscle Arius is he
serious you're damn right I'm serious
I'm not surprised you don't remember
that hey guys this missions gonna be on
awesome let's do it I don't know I just
don't know wow this isn't the Luther I
used to know you used to be crazy meant
if you remember that time the summer of
1982 when you got so drunk you hooked up
with donkeys 34 year old half-sister and
peed on the rug
there was nothing any physical evidence
that I had anything to do with it that's
not true I got a video of that somewhere
the ISIS missions gonna be awesome all
we got to do is prime the security guard
some pizza sneak into the ventilation
shaft like we used to do to get out of
eighth grade gym class - how old the
file a check my email and you really
think we can do this not really boots me
fun get drunk
all right guys a man in wow this place
is awesome it looks like something out
of Star Wars okay five or six like
friends to me a video of a dog and a
surfboard Salieri's what do you want me
to type in a w-9 okay but first you got
to go to youtube and type in dog on a
surfboard fine I'll do the important
stuff the finals are in the computer its
rooms oh and ER I love that movie can't
move it
alright guys pull me up yeah we did it
to pay good team effort you'll get it
done a mission impossible to